in the wild animals affect each other's
behavior all the time
prey species keep away from predators
turf insects jump away from browsing
herbivores they may not be communicating
per se but they shape each other's
environment to further explore this
relationship researchers used robots to
mediate between two species unlikely to
ever encounter each other in the wild
zebrafish and honey bees the researchers
chose these species because they're both
social and gregarious animals who
regularly make decisions as a group to
do these experiments the animals were
kept apart in fact they're in different
countries in Switzerland a small school
of zebrafish swim around a circular path
with a camera overhead tracking their
position swimming along with them is a
robot ler the same size and shape as a
zebrafish meanwhile in Austria a swarm
of young bees buzz around an oblong
enclosure with two robots in the middle
the bee BOTS generate heat which causes
the bees to congregate around them a
proximity detector attracts the bees
location and each set up the fish and
bees have a binary collective choice to
make the bees can choose to congregate
around one of two robots and the fish
can swim either clockwise or counter
clockwise around the circle the
researchers wanted to know if using
robots as mediators the two species
could come to a collective decision
could the species agreed which direction
to swim in and which bee robot to gather
around for different experiments were
performed with varying degrees of
communication between the animal groups
the first experiment established a
control group with no communication
between the fish and the bees and the
second experiment the bees behavior was
observed and then transmitted to the
fish robot affecting which way it lured
the school of zebrafish after six
minutes
the bees began to congregate or on the
Left bee robot causing the fish robot
and as a result the fish to swim in a
counterclockwise direction in the third
experiment the fish's behavior was
observed and then transmitted to the be
robots affecting which robot produced
heat the fish constantly changed the
direction in which they were swimming
which caused the Beast can
tenuously switch sides as well in the
final experiment the behavior of both
the bees and the fish was observed and
transmitted both ways
at first the fish and bees couldn't come
to a decision once I did one thing the
other another with lots of switching
back and forth but after about 20
minutes they reached a consensus with
the fish swimming counterclockwise and
the bees congregating on the Left bee
robot this shows that two species which
would have no interaction whatsoever in
nature are actually able to interact and
come to a collective decision thanks to
the help of the robots moving forward
researchers would like to introduce
machine learning into these types of
scenarios so bee BOTS learn behavior
from bees and fish BOTS from fish
instead of being programmed ahead of
time researchers believe that in the
future this technology could be used to
mediate species interaction not just in
the laboratory but also in the wild the
research could even be adapted to work
with plants fungi and microorganisms one
day machine learning robots could be
used to perceive a dramatic event in a
bee colony and react to help the bees to
find a way to recover this could be
applied to any type of animal group once
the robot knows how they make collective
decisions